at the end of the dance with dragons and
of season five of Game of Thrones
Jon Snow is stabbed and seemingly killed
by men of the Nights Watch the men do
this because Jon as Lord Commander
brings thousands of wildlings south of
the wall he tries to unite with them
against the White Walkers and to save
them from being killed and added to the
army of the Dead but the watch has been
fighting wildlings for thousands of
years and many brothers have deep
personal grudges they see wildlings as
savages and fear they'll destroy the
watch or at least eat all their precious
food come winter upset with all the bold
changes Jon makes at the wall they
whisper that jon is a rebel a turn cloak
and a traitor the last straw in the
books is when Jon announced a plan to
ride south against Ramsay Bolton in
Winterfell to rescue his half-sister
that's when the brothers stabbed him for
the watch so it looks like Jon Snow is
dead and apparently not coming back Game
of Thrones is repeating a lesson they've
taught us before good guys die Ned gets
beheaded Rob gets red wedded cat gets a
throat cut
it seems like whenever someone tries to
do the right thing in Westeros they get
screwed over by people like Littlefinger
and Roose Bolton this has been a pretty
bleak season King's Landing is run by
bigoted zealots creepy necromancer's and
fools and Cersei is ruthlessly
humiliated Sansa is set up to be all
empowered but you just get beaten down
by the Bolton's I assets' off a grand
adventure and becomes a vicious faceless
assassin Jamie tries to rescue Marcella
but he fails and she dies Brienne tries
to rescue Sansa but she fails and all
she achieves is the death of Stannis who
himself is kind of a good guy on till he
burns his daughter brain is forgotten
beyond the wall becoming a psychic tree
boy or something and gods know where
recon is it's not all bad with Daenerys
when she is not burning innocent men
alive but she's still in Essos with no
sign of going west any time soon in
Westeros it's like we're all out of
Heroes all out of hope the White Walkers
look unstoppable and at this point some
may welcome our new ice demon overlords
they're probably preferable to people
like Littlefinger and the Bolton's some
people think Jon Snow's corpse will be
added to the
army of the Dead will be converted into
a white Walker to lead it against the
living it feels like the bad guys of one
game over
but Game of Thrones is not just a story
of death and loss the book series is
titled A Song of Ice and Fire
there are two sides in this story there
is balance there's hope and in many ways
Jon Snow embodies it in the show he's
been clearly set up in opposition to the
darkness to the leader of the White
Walkers apparently called the night king
surely you don't have an awesome
standoff like this without a payoff
later on and John is central to many of
the unresolved mysteries and prophecies
of the series R plus l equals J a very
popular and well supported Theory claims
that Jon Snow's parents are not Ned
Stark and an unknown woman but Ned's
sister Lyanna stark and the Targaryen
Prince Rhaegar which has a lot of big
implications including maybe giving John
a claim on the throne the prophecy of
azor Ahai states that certain signs
herald the coming of a hero of the Lord
of Light someone to drive back the White
Walkers in the long night Melisandre
believes that Stannis is this hero but
evidence suggests it may actually be
John however you look at it Jon Snow has
unfinished business in Westeros he may
be this hope that seems to be missing
from the story so is there any way he
can come back and finish what he started
the answer maybe Melisandre we know from
beric Dondarrion and Thoris of Mir that
red priests can bring the dead back to
life we've never seen Melisandre
resurrect anyone that in the books she
says her magic is becoming stronger at
the wall and that she can do things that
she has never done before and in the
show Melisandre visits laurels of Mir
maybe comparing notes on resurrection so
it's totally reasonable to think that
Melisandre may be capable of bringing
the dead back to life and she does take
a definite interest in Jon in the books
Melisandre for sees his stabbing warning
Jon of daggers in the dark and telling
him that he'll have grave need of her
that she's his only hope in the show she
said some interesting things about her
joining with Jon having power to make
life and light and she turns up at the
wall conveniently in time for his
stabbing Melisandre is actress Carice
van Houten has
strongly hinted that something's going
to happen between Melisandre and John
after John stabbing all this evidence
makes it seem very likely that
Melisandre resurrects Jon Snow but there
may be a cost
we're told over and over that only death
can pay for life and a dance
specifically emphasizes that Melisandre
needs Kings blood to perform her magic
there's this whole subplot about Jon
sending a Montague Aryan and mance
rayder's son with Sam and Gilly down to
Old Town because Amon has the blood of
Targaryen Kings and Mance's son has the
blood of the king-beyond-the-wall
so John fears Melisandre will want to
burn them but there's still someone left
at the wall with King's blood Shireen
Baratheon daughter of King Stannis
Melisandre might burn Shireen to
resurrect Jon in the show Melisandre has
already burned Shireen to clear the
snows slowing Stannis she comes to the
wall soon after so maybe in the show she
is still juiced up with King's blood
magic child sacrifice Bell in the books
at least it seems pretty likely that
Melisandre will use the sacrifice of
Shireen to resurrect Jon Snow Jon's
resurrection may also involve skin
changing which the show calls worgen
walking is the ability to enter the mind
of animal like bran enters the mind of
his direwolf summer the three-eyed crow
tells brand that if he died as part of
him would remain in summer in the
prologue of Dance a wildling walk
Faramir six skins tells us that when a
warg dies they can live a second life by
walking into the animal after death and
in the prologue of air Amir does this he
dies but lives on in his wolf ver Amir
also specifically tells us that Jon Snow
is a powerful warg and that living on in
Jon's direwolf ghost would be a second
life worthy of a king
Jon definitely is a walk though he
resists it he accidentally enters the
mind of ghost a bunch of times and this
connection with his wolf grows stronger
in dance Jon says ghost is a part of him
that he and ghost are one just like bran
says he and summer are one Melisandre
urges Jon to embrace this power and
tells him he'd do well to keep his wolf
close beside him at the end of the book
after jon is stabbed his last word is
ghost
finally Melisandre has a vision of John
changing from a man to wolf to a man
again in the show ghost hasn't been seen
for a while and there's been none of
this skin changing the shadowing so
maybe in the show John will just be
straight-up resurrected by Melisandre
but in the books at least this evidence
strongly suggests that on his death
John wargs into his direwolf ghost and
later becomes a man once more probably
via resurrection by Melisandre with the
sacrifice of Shireen this resurrection
fits really well with mysteries and
prophecies surrounding Jon Snow if R
plus L equal J is true and John is the
son of Prince Rhaegar Targaryen John has
some claim on the Iron Throne in his vow
to the Nights Watch
John swears to wear no crown but his vow
says his watch ends with his death John
does die so he's surely freed of this
oath allowing him after his resurrection
to once more take part in the politics
of Westeros and perhaps to make a claim
on the throne this gives new meaning to
veremey a statement that a second life
in ghost would be worthy of the King
Jon's resurrection also fits with the
prophecy of azor Ahai Melisandre is
starting to realize that the prophesied
hero of the Lord of Light is not Stannis
it's Jon there's this moment in the show
where you can see it in her face when
she realizes she's been supporting the
wrong guy all this time in dance
Melisandre prays for a glimpse of azor
Ahai and her God role or repeatedly
shows her John's
oh it looks like jon is azor Ahai and
this resurrection helps him fit the
prophesied science it said that
sacrifice may be required for the
rebirth of azor Ahai and the sacrifice
of Shireen could fulfill that other
signs of azor Ahai includes smoke and
salt which may be provided by the smoke
and the tears of shereen's burning
further Melisandre goes on and on about
using Kings blood to wake dragons from
stone maybe the King's blood is
Shireen's the stone is Shireen's
greyscale her stone like skin condition
and the dragon is Jon Targaryen you
might think that's kind of a lame of
symbolic fulfillment of Mel's waking
Dragons from stone but it's actually
very very similar to something George R
Martin has done before in his novella of
the mystery Knight in this story there's
a prediction that a dragon will be
and what this ends up referring to is
the symbolic emergence of the young boy
egg as a true Targaryen Prince Aegon and
when you also consider that Melisandre
admits that she sometimes misinterpret
sir prophesies and visions and that they
can often be symbolic in nature it seems
totally possible that Melisandre talk of
waking dragons from stone means the
rebirth of John as a Targaryen with a
sacrifice of Shireen some people got
further with this idea suggesting that
after being resurrected John will
sentence Melisandre to death for the
crime of killing Shireen we know that
Ned always told his sons and John that
the man who passes the sentence should
swing the blade so John would kill the
fire priestess with his Valyrian steel
sword Longclaw maybe if he does this the
sword will take on her flame becoming
Azeroth eyes prophesied flaming sword
Lightbringer this is just speculation
but if it all happens it would fulfil
almost every sign of the prophecy of
azor Ahai and would neatly tie together
a whole bunch of plot threads one more
possibility is that when John dies and
his spirit enters ghost he will have a
vision that reveals r+ l equals J the
truth of his parentage in The Dance with
Dragons prologue when Vera Muir is dying
and about to begin his second life in
his wolf he has this moment where his
spirit becomes one with nature and he
looks out through the eyes of a weirwood
tree maybe Jon will have a similar
experience when he dies and begins his
second life in his wolf the reason why
this is important is that bran Stark is
taught by the three-eyed crow to do the
same thing to leave his body and become
one with nature and to see through the
eyes of weirwood trees when bran does
this he has visions of the past of Ned
and other Starks and others further back
in the past so if when Jon dies he
experiences being one with nature in the
where woods as Vermeer does bran who is
also on though we would network might
share with John his visions this might
sound unlikely but it actually already
happened in a Clash of Kings Jon has a
wolf's dream a walking dream featuring a
weirwood with his brother's face this
tree boy figure representing brand gives
John a vision of mance rayder's wildling
army so yeah we've got a bit of an
inception visions within dreams plus
possible time travels
sort of thing happening here but the
important point is that bran can give
Shawn visions by connecting with him
through the worgen greensight we
wouldn't work thing so if John becomes
one with the weirwoods when he dies and
enters his wolf jobs as Vermeer does it
would totally be possible for brand to
give John a vision just like he does in
clash and since brands visions can see
into the past
maybe bran will give John a vision of
his real parents Rhaegar and Lyanna
possibly of the secret marriage they may
have heard of the weirwood Grove at the
Isle of faces with John's death he may
learn the truth of his birth again this
is just speculation just an idea but it
would make a lot of sense it would
explain why george RR martin has john
entered the mind of his direwolf before
returning to his body instead of just
being resurrected by Melisandre and
would give a plot purpose to all this
weird entering the weirwood stuff that's
associated with the second lives of logs
and it would finally reveal R + L equals
J which doesn't really have any other
way of being revealed on this Howland
Reed decides to finally arrive and how
cool would it be this guy not only gets
brought back from the dead released from
his vows fulfilling an ancient prophecy
of the rebirth of a hero but is born
again with the knowledge of his true
identity as John Targaryen it's all very
biblical a man of kinda and mysterious
birth goes around saying some sensible
things about loving thy neighbor like
making peace with the wildlings but he
gets betrayed and killed by his friends
before a cross like don't tell me that's
not a cross and he stays dead for a bit
but then is reborn as a divine hero
so yeah in conclusion Jon Snow is Game
of Thrones Jesus or at least there's
evidence that Jon Snow will return and
that the next book is going to be a hell
of a raid
let's end there for the evidence that
jon is the son of lion a stark and
rhaegar targaryen check out the r + l
equals j video for a discussion of the
azure Ahai prophecy
check out the azure 'hi video for an
explanation of magneto encephalography
check out the MA G video cuz yeah why
not right it's about brain imaging it's
got mind-reading and Robo hands in it
you might like it thank you for watching
feel free to comment what you think will
happen to Jon Snow and what topic you'd
like to see splined next